we i first have to start off with what
the hell is in this smoothie that
everyone loves
this purple smoothie yes
okay so
i launched a smoothie with
earth bar which is where where what
state are you in by the way i'm in
arizona you're in arizona okay so you're
not far yeah
um
there are earth bars it's like it's like
a smoothie shop all around california
does it have food too i feel like is
there one in laguna
i believe so yeah but anyway so i
launched a smoothie with them it's
called the genius smoothie
and it's super tasty i was never much of
a smoothie guy
but um
but i launched the smoothie with them
which is like not overly sweet there's
no bananas in it i feel like most of the
time you go to a you know get a smoothie
it's like all frozen banana just leaves
you in a glycemic coma afterwards so
mine is like primarily blueberries and
we get a little bit of frozen avocado
which is a very low glycemic yeah
rich in healthy fats
um
and then some whey protein which is
super high biological value
uh source of essential amino acids and
branched chain amino acids and then
cinnamon a cacao extract that's
yeah it's it tastes like an oatmeal
cookie it's really freaking good and
people have been loving it which is
awesome
that's awesome well i would totally
check it with my continuous blood
glucose monitor to
but everyone's different that's the one
thing i found is that um with like
checking your blood sugar definitely
there are some things that just don't
spike it as much but um it's it's a
little individual
yeah but it's a good it's uh that sounds
delicious
it sounds like something i would put
like if i were going to do it i i mean
like a little banana's lovely like a
quarter of a banana even just to like
make it creamy but the avocado does the
job yeah it's creamy
yes you would like it i think and people
that follow me have been who wear cgms
yeah i've been posting some i mean i've
seen like two or three people post like
their curves
and it doesn't seem to spike blood sugar
at all amazing yeah it's good
yeah it's a it's like a brain boosting
smoothie that also has great a great
source of protein
good for muscle protein synthesis
and um and yeah it's cool you know like
in la we've got there's the haley bieber
smoothie
over it over at arowan and then there's
like the max luca beer
genius smoothie at earth bar so it's
like it feels kind of cool to be in that
arena you know uh so what are you into
these days like what i mean when it
comes to like health i feel like people
ask me all the time they're like what
are you eating these days like what are
you doing these days people when they're
when i'm traveling and working and they
have to order meals for me or get meals
for whatever it is i'm doing events or
planes or anything they're like
what are you eating um so i feel like
there's always something in the testing
and being tested and run so
like what is that for you right now
yeah i mean you know i
i think i continue to advocate for
um
the
consumption of minimally processed foods
like animals and plants which is like so
controversial online and to me it's like
the least controversial thing ever
um
but you know like people people in the
nutrition space they're very polarized
by their
by their diet tribes whatever those
happen to be whether it's like the
plant-based community or the carnivore
community or like the low-carb community
or the keto community
yeah um the things that i'm really
enjoying talking about lately
um
i've been sort of i actually my views on
dairy have changed i don't know where
you were used to stand on dairy but i
used to be like when i first got into
the wellness world there's this dogma
that like dairy is bad it's like you
know it's like oh yeah i didn't eat
dairy for years yeah
and and i get it like a lot of people
are lactose intolerant and um
and you get a lot of pressure from the
plant-based community not to consume
dairy and there's a lot of money from
the plant-based alternative like milks
you know to steer consumers away from
dairy but if you actually look at like
what it is
it's an incredibly nutrient-dense food
it's one of the most nutrient-dense
foods
um available to people right and it's
very inexpensive and it's got all these
like micronutrients in it great source
of protein
especially when you look at specific
dairy products like greek yogurt or
um
whey protein which i'm a big fan of
and and i'm not sponsored by the dairy
industry it's just that i've sort of i
went and i looked at the research on
dairy and it's really not like it's not
inflammatory like there's like this
people think that like milk is an
intrinsically inflammatory it's not and
so
um i've been enjoying sort of like
talking about that a bit because i think
it's really important especially
when you're in a position
of influence
in the in the nutrition sphere to share
with people where your views change you
know because that's what science is it's
like iterative
and if you're not willing if you're not
willing to check your
your beliefs and your assumptions
um on a regular basis
then you're not
really
that's like not scientific you know
you're just like being dogmatic yeah and
exactly
yeah so i have i agree i let's see i
went gluten and dairy free probably like
back in like 2013 and then
probably 2015 paleo and then i stayed
like that for quite a while
um until probably
last year maybe 2021-ish
and but now this sort of raw
dairy market is very intriguing and
when you think about
the um how many
health how much healthy bacteria and
how much bioavailable nutrients there
are and it's not stripped with heat and
all these processing
mechanisms to clean it um you kind of
having a live food versus a dead food
and so i
and then i also do more of goat cheese
i've always loved goat cheese but i cut
that out even for that time period so
goat cheese and feta because it's goat
and sheep right so it's not really dairy
essentially
um i believe that that's well that's
what i've been told um and then raw and
then some raw stuff so raw cream
kefir or kefir how do you pronounce it
i think it's kefir but kefir sounds more
like legit like you know in its origin
language like i could i would believe
that it's more like that target versus
target yeah exactly so we'll go with
kefir yeah um and um butter raw butter
so all the raw stuff and you guys can
get that pretty easy in california
it is pretty easy to find yeah i think i
like sprouts we now have raw dairy and i
allegedly raw dairy i haven't vetted
this for myself but raw dairy has
it has lactose in it which is the
problematic sugar that people 75 of the
global population has difficulty
digesting but it also
allegedly has lactase in it which is the
enzyme so
what lactose intolerance is is an
inability to produce the lactase enzyme
which breaks down lactose
but apparently in uh
and again this is just like i'm
i haven't vetted this but apparently raw
dairy has lactase in it to make it
you can basically like easily digest it
even if you're lactose intolerant so
nature made it perfect yeah
yeah i mean so i'm a big fan of like
minimally processed foods and like
animal products i think really really
valuable um i've been sort of batting
heads with uh
you know a lot of the science coming out
lately is um really i mean
seemingly funded by the food industry
and and i think with the intent of
leading consumers
astray well i don't know if that's the
intent but it certainly seems that way
and um
and you know there's this push i think
towards
like highly processed ultra processed
foods these days
um from our most trusted academic
institutions you know and i think it's a
big problem i mean today 60 of of people
consume like the calories that most
people consume are by and large from
these like ultra processed foods these
are the foods that line our supermarket
aisles they're shelf-stable
they're not real they're like not even
real food
exactly and they're really the
foundation of the epidemic of modern
chronic disease which includes obesity
and um and and you'd be surprised how
much like
dissuading
consumers from those kinds of foods you
actually get like pushback from
from like the industry you know and it's
just like really maddening that's their
cognitive distance you have cognitive
dissonance around seeing a character in
a movie playing a different role but
these people are like don't mess with my
pop-tarts those are my life yeah
and they're all i mean i think they're
all
chills for the for the food industry at
this point it's really sad
um and i and so i understand why why so
many consumers are confused when it
comes to like what it means to eat
healthily these days
um so yeah it's cheaper too i mean you
look at a lot of stuff i mean you know
things that take giant
multi-million dollar billion dollar
industries with
factories and all these you know trucks
and everything it takes to get the
product to market and then it's a dollar
nineteen and then you see something else
that's pulled out of the dirt and put on
a
shelf and it's
5.99 and so it's
it seems counterintuitive like why do
you think
why do you think that there's such a
difficulty for people to transition
to
recognizing how
bad some things are for you
well i think a lot of it does come from
the from the food industry i mean you
you walk through like your average
supermarket and there's some ridiculous
percentage i forget exactly what it is
but by and large super the supermarkets
are filled these days with these kinds
of foods right and these are the foods
that
make health claims
so like
you see the red heart healthy logo on
the canola oil right but you don't
typically see it on extra virgin olive
oil
right or a beet you know it's not like
there's a sticker that says like good
for your heart yeah exactly on beets or
on or on broccoli or even on even on
eggs right like eggs are one of nature's
perfect foods like